last video I talked about a strategy of
betting called the martingale system
it's a strategy where you always chase
the total amount you've lost so far by
betting that total amount plus 2 so that
when you eventually do win you will win
2 guaranteed a lot of you saw the flaw
in the system was that the amount of
money you'd need to sustain it would be
infinite the issue is that even if you
have a really huge amount of money as
long as it's finite the expectation
value from playing this game is zero
that's because with a very small chance
you'd run out of money to keep betting
and you'd lose a lot I didn't believe
this until I did the calculation because
it just seems so unlikely to even lose
that many times in a row that you didn't
really need to worry about getting to
the stage where you'd be betting big so
you didn't have to worry about folding
but let's do the calculation and see
what happens everyone has some number of
losses that would mean they've lost
enough money that they wouldn't be able
to pay the amount that they need for the
next round and so they would have to
give up let's call this number of losses
for a particular person and and can be
very high or very low it doesn't matter
the person only has a 1 in 2 to the end
chance of losing this maximum n times in
a row and if they don't lose then they
win - and that's most of the time with a
probability of 1 minus 1 over 2 to the N
but in the unlikely event that they do
lose their total loss is this sum of
losses so far which we know is 2 to the
n plus 1 minus 2 so we put all of this
together in the expectation value
formula the probability of not folding
times the gain plus the probability of
folding times loss and it magically
works out to 0 the way to explain this
is that when you play the strategy with
a good probability you win a modest game
but with a small probability you will
make a disastrous fall and it averages
out to 0 in expectation the higher your
value of n the less likely you'll lose
when you play this game as n approaches
infinity the chance you can fail goes to
zero in the version where a person can
always afford to gamble more they will
always make - as a lot of you pointed
out the casino also has a maximum bet
for this very reason so everyone has to
stop playing eventually
so the strategy clearly doesn't work if
you play it lots of times you'll end up
with zero on average but once you're
only played it a few times and what if
you capped your maximum bet at a very
reasonable price so that you wouldn't
mind too much if you did lose even
though it does mean you'll lose more
often let's try an example say you set
your maximum times of losing at 4 the
probability of losing any one round then
is just 1 in 16 so you think you'd be
pretty safe if you only played a small
number of rounds compared to 16 for
example for but the thing is you'd lose
money unless you won every single one of
those rounds but the probability of that
is only around 77% nowhere near a
guarantee especially considering how
much you stand to lose plus the amount
that you can win is just 8 my opinion
you'd be way better off getting a job
that solves the paradox entirely for the
real world as far as I'm concerned but
there's still a paradox in my opinion
mathematically let's look at the game
where the person playing never runs out
of money you might say well that would
require them to have an infinite amount
of money already
not really since each time they play
they only bet a finite amount and they
can always borrow money to play because
they're guaranteed to make it back and
you might say well there isn't even an
infinite amount of money in the world
for them that they could borrow sure but
max doesn't care what sort of world
we're in we could have been in a
universe with different physics that
allowed the universe to be infinite and
the maps would be the same so this is
the paradox for me mathematically this
random red or black game should have
expectation zero you just feel like that
must be true there's no way on average
to make money from a game as complete
chance but what's the expectation of the
martingale well
it's two you will always win two or
using the mathematical formula we can
see the same thing in fact I can make
this number anything I want for example
I can bet fifty more than my total
losses each time then the expectation is
fifty but I can make it worse again by
using this strategy say you've lost a
few times so far and it's the enthroned
then bet all that you've lost so far
plus two to the power of n look at that
expectation value it's infinite
so the real paradox for me is that you
can somehow take a game that you think
should have expectations zero and then
actually make the expectation whatever
you want including infinity and yet when
you restrict to realistic cases you
always get zero this paradox showed me
that my intuition about expectation
values is wrong there are situations
where it breaks down badly that's why I
really like paradoxes if the mathematics
is sound it means that the unsound thing
is something in your own way of
reasoning it forces you to acknowledge
that